[Musique]
on se voit on se voit pas ce dégrader au
fil du temps
j'arrive à l'exprimer mais où c'est
compliqué de revenir sur ces moments là
j'avais honte dans parler de blessure
pourquoi moi pourquoi j'étais touché
c'est d'autant plus dur à accepter et
effectivement c'est une petite enfin
c'est une longue descente aux enfers
[Musique]
David ont un point commun tous les trois
sont atteints d'un syndrome
psychotromatique lié à leur engagement
militaire
une blessure invisible encore méconnue
aujourd'hui reconnu comme un enjeu
majeur et ce au plus haut niveau du
ministère des armées
nous les avons suivis dans leur nouveau
combat celui de la reconstruction
[Musique]
accompagné de son coach Thomas Pascal
nous donne rendez-vous à l'aube sur les
bords de Loire
un paysage sauvage comme une invitation
au voyage
commando au sein de l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace cette Orléanais de 36 ans
s'est lancé un défi fou descendre cet
hiver la loi en kayak en 5 jours
[Musique]
entre les différentes poches de sable
même quand tu vas couper si tu coupes
entre les deux bouts là donc tu vas
avoir toujours le même courant
ce que je recherche vraiment
c'est un contact
un contact fort avec avec la nature avec
les éléments
donc l'hiver c'est très bien tout est
rigoureux il fait froid je peux avoir
peur à être dans le doute avoir faim et
fatigué et donc me mettre dans cette
situation ça m'oblige à aller chercher
au fond au fond de moi aller chercher le
dash chez la force morale et chercher de
l'endurance physique chercher de la
volonté et
ça me libère de faire ça
c'est parti c'est parti
pour réussir Pascal devra suivre un
rythme effréné de près de 150 km par
jour seul et sans assistance soit un
parcours total de 750 km des contraintes
qui ne lui font pas peur
c'est une forme de lâcher prise en fait
on se laisse porter par le courant et on
subit pas non plus d'ailleurs on
accompagne on dirige notre kayak je
trouve que c'est
ouais c'est un parallèle avec ce que
j'ai pas su faire pendant un certain
temps c'est à dire de me laisser aller
mais en continuant à quand même à
piloter tout ça de manière douce
c'est flagrant va être un peu paradoxal
il faut que je bouge pour que les choses
se reposent mais je le vis comme ça oui
à l'origine de ce défi une terrible
expérience en mission Afghanistan des
soldats de son unité sont blessés l'un
de perlavie ces deux ans plus tard en
sortant des obsèques d'un autre
militaire mort en opération que Pascal
s'effondre
et là j'ai attaqué la face dure du
syndrome post-traumatique après cette
phase latente ou donc j'ai commencé par
des
scènes une obsession
des pensées obsessionnelles sur sur
cette action ces moments précis du
combat qui m'est revenu en pleine figure
alors que c'était plus de deux ans
auparavant donc voilà je m'y attendais
absolument pas et tout d'un coup je me
suis retrouvé prochaine dans cette dans
cette action
ou je revoyais chaque détail chacun de
mes gestes et une fois qu'on est dans
cette spirale on a beau se raisonner à
dire bah non j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
la situation était comme ça
j'ai pas pu arrêter le mécanisme qui
était qui était lancé
l'origine du syndrome psychotrumatique
n'est pas uniquement lié à des actions
de combat c'est la confrontation à un
voire plusieurs événements traumatisants
qui vient blesser le psychisme d'un
individu il peut provoquer des symptômes
comme l'hypervigilance des cauchemars
des flashbacks ou encore des crises
d'angoisse
parce que j'ai ressenti qui je pense a
été partagé par d'autres blessés
c'est aussi de ne pas
vouloir être pris en charge
pourtant il y a des structures qui sont
de plus en plus adaptées c'est blessures
qui commencent à être connu moi il m'a
fallu quelques coups de pied aux fesses
de mon entourage très proche
pour que j'aille voir des médecins pour
que
pour que je
fasse une vraie démarche de
reconstruction de suivi de prise en
charge parce que moi je ne voulais pas y
aller
[Musique]
j'attends ton repas aujourd'hui Pascal
est en congé du blessé une période de
convalescence de 6 à 18 mois pendant
laquelle il restera attaché à son unité
c'est là que pour moi les choses ont
changé c'est-à-dire que le fait
d'admettre profondément vis-à-vis de moi
la blessure et de devoir l'afficher
parce que j'avais pas le choix de voir
l'afficher autour de moi ça m'a permis
de découvrir les réactions de ceux qui
selon moi allez me juger en me montrant
du doigt qui au contraire
nous on peut te proposer ça écoute nous
on peut t'aider ou bravo et des gens
m'ont dit bravo c'est courageeux de
d'avoir accepté de tout arrêter ce qu'il
faut avoir était tout l'inverse si je
fais ça je suis le dernier de
dernier délai des tire-flancs ça le mot
c'est pire au flan je vais pas m'arrêter
parce que ça va pas
c'est bienveillance
a été
ensuite le moteur qui m'a permis de
d'assumer cette blessure et d'en parler
pour mener à bien son défi sur la Loire
Pascal profite d'un élan de solidarité
plus de 24 partenaires le soutiennent
comme la Fondation des gueules cassées
le fabricant de kayaks ne tired qui
fournit les unités de commando ou encore
la base aérienne d'Orléans
[Musique]
mais cette action n'est que
l'aboutissement d'une préparation
collective formidable et qui me porte
qui me
en fait qui m'a aussi aidé à aller de
l'avant à retrouver enfin à retrouver
des sensations positives centre du
courant
et
on y va
un défi sportif pour Pascal mais pour se
reconstruire d'autres voies sont
possibles
en 2021 le ministère des armées crée une
nouvelle structure la maison Atos
[Musique]
un projet piloté par l'armée de terre
est mise en œuvre Paris GESA
ce dispositif non médicalisé expérimente
une nouvelle approche dans la
reconstruction de militaires atteint
d'un syndrome psychotraumatique lié au
service
William 31 ans 11 années de service dans
les troupes aéroportées de l'armée de
terre et l'un des premiers à avoir
intégré la maison Atos de Cambes en
Gironde si la aujourd'hui accepté de
témoigner s'exprimer devant notre caméra
reste un exercice difficile
entre 2017 et 2018 dans le Normandie au
sein de la détachement d'accompagnement
autorité et malheureusement j'étais
confronté à des événements traumatisants
non dans cette ambiance si particulière
et très hostile qui est lequel Mali et
mon retour à la maison s'est fait
difficilement donc je m'en suis pas
forcément rendu compte moi-même ça s'est
fait petit à petit
que ma compagne l'a remarqué me l'a dit
à nombreuses reprises que ça n'allait
pas qu'il fallait que je fasse quelque
chose
dans mon cadre professionnel je manquais
de plus en plus d'assiduités ce qui m'a
valu une sanction disciplinaire à la fin
de de mon service et ça a été le
déclenchement de ma petite descente aux
enfers donc j'ai eu la chance de de
bénéficier du soutien inconditionnel de
ma compagne qui a su qui ont commencé
aujourd'hui faire face
aux mots qui me pèse et qui met en péril
une autre couple William consulte un
psychiatre à Bordeaux qui décèle un
syndrome psychotromatique potentiel
l'hôpital militaire de la région Robert
Picqué confirme le diagnostic une fois
l'état de William stabilisé le corps
médical propose son dossier à la maison
Atos
c'est la force du dispositif Atos réunit
l'ensemble des acteurs du parcours de
soins et de reconstruction du blessé
c'est vrai qu'on a un rôle sur Atos qui
est vraiment de créer ce lien de
proximité ça ça j'insiste là-dessus qui
pour moi est très important pour créer
cette relation de confiance pour animer
appuyer le réseau en fait le réseau de
blessés qu'on retrouve ici à TOS et ça
c'est une première c'est à dire que le
blessé va avoir sur un même lieu toutes
les personnes qui œuvrent à son profit
et de pouvoir retrouver à la fois les
gens qui travaillaient Atos mais aussi
la cabate les assistantes sociales Paul
des forces mobilité lui évite de cette
fatigue en fait que l'on retrouve
notamment chez San Andreas traumatique
d'aller chercher l'information c'est
nous qui venons à lui
donc la porte d'entrée c'est souvent les
démarches administratives les parcours
administratifs du blessé les questions
financières aussi parce que tout ça
c'est très lié et parfois aussi les
résonances intrafamiliales avec des
séparations des divorces des droits de
garde voilà l'idée c'est de proposer un
premier enseignement et s'il y a besoin
d'un accompagnement plus poussé
on oriente comme on a l'habitude de le
faire partout ailleurs sur les
professionnels compétents et moi je suis
ici pour les aider à des fois trouver
simplement une orientation leur donner
une idée de deuxième carrière et leur
faire mettre en avant leurs compétences
qu'ils ont souvent pas du tout
conscience et pour arriver derrière un
projet et arriver au projet avec
éventuellement une formation ou une
immersion ou
dans une entreprise on a dit bonjour et
en même temps depuis un an la maison a
fêté des réussites notamment des
reconversions dans des secteurs aussi
variés que la mécanique ou
l'informatique
au quotidien la maison fonctionne en
cogestion entre la soixantaine de
membres et l'équipe encadrante trois
accompagnateurs et le directeur pierre
un ancien militaire
la réhabilitation psychosociale la base
c'est l'un pour omment c'est redevenir
acteur de sa vie donc l'idée n'est pas
de pousser ou de faire à la place de
mais de proposer ou de laisser
l'initiative naître et de l'encourager
voilà donc d'être là pour donner de
l'inspiration parfois l'initiative vient
du monde civile ça prend un peu de temps
même si vous
avez une semaine par mois Sophie
comédienne et met deux en scène donne
des cours de théâtre aux membres de la
maison
c'est son mari militaire qui la
sensibilisé à la blessure psychique
on s'est demandé comment faire relier
nos deux professions et on a eu cette
envie commune
lui a beaucoup
[Musique]
j'ai connu ce trauma non pas tellement
personnellement mais qu'avec les hommes
avec qui il est parti et ça l'a marqué
ça la il en a accompagné beaucoup et
c'est quelque chose c'est une trace qui
reste chez lui et un moment il m'a dit
mais peut-être qu'on pourra faire
quelque chose avec le théâtre voilà et
comme à ce moment là le processus a tous
démarré
c'est comme ça que ça a pu se
s'imbriquer et se rencontrer dès que
c'est quotidien et que c'est plus diffus
et que c'est très en rapport avec la
réalité et que le choix est pas très
radical c'est beaucoup plus dur pour
votre imaginaire de suivre David 44 ans
n'aurait jamais pensé se mettre en scène
tout simplement cet objet vous allez
pouvoir en grignoter un petit morceau et
vous n'aurez plus aucune sensation de
fatigue pendant un mois en 2001 alors
soldat de l'armée de terre il est
projeté un Afghanistan
il en revient blessé mais va poursuivre
ses missions avant d'être réformé en
ce n'est que 20 ans plus tard qu'il
décide de composer le numéro d'écoute
défense un déclic qui va l'amener
jusqu'ici
la blessure c'est des moments beaucoup
en s'isole ou on ne parle pas on
s'exprime pas ou le corps n'est plus en
activité ou
[Musique]
on s'éteint petit à petit et le fait de
venir à Atos et de pouvoir bénéficier
des ateliers théâtres c'est refaire
prendre vie au corps à la parole
et reprendre vie tout court
mais rassurez-vous qu'on a longtemps
pensé que tout était derrière nous
revivre ce genre de d'émotion c'est fort
c'est fort et c'est très fatigant parce
que parce qu'on était plus habitués quoi
c'est très fatigant et
et mais comme je vous le disais c'est
encore très très encourageant et en
progresse moi je vous fais un
personnellement moi je me surprends à
aller vite enfin finalement c'est ma
prise en charge est récente entre le
moment où j'ai vécu ce traumatisme et ma
prise en charge et c'est presque
dérouler 20 ans j'ai vécu avec ça j'ai
habitué mon corps à vivre avec je me
suis créé des échappatoires pour éviter
des des lieux ou des moments que je
pouvais pas supporter aujourd'hui il
existe deux maisons Atos l'unissi près
de Bordeaux l'autre à Toulon une
troisième maison devrait t'ouvrir ses
portes courant 2022 en région
Rhône-Alpes et d'autres maisons
régionales pourraient s'envisager à
terme
depuis 10 ans le service de santé des
armées déploie des plans d'action pour
renforcer la formation des praticiens et
structurer au mieux le parcours de soins
du blessé
la reconnaissance de la blessure
psychique n'a pas toujours été une
évidence
[Musique]
tout ce cristallise en 14-18 une guerre
meurtrière marquée par l'apparition de
nouvelles armes
[Musique]
dans les hôpitaux de l'arrière le
service de santé des armées soigne des
militaires victimes de tremblements de
tiques et de cauchemars des blessures
qu'on peinent à nommer et à comprendre
les psychiatres militaires de l'époque
parlent d'abusite une référence au choc
provoquée par l'explosion des obus ou
encore d'hypnose des batailles mais la
psychiatrie marque une avancée décisive
[Musique]
la prise en compte de la blessure
psychique franchit une nouvelle étape en
1990 avec l'imminence de la guerre du
Golfe
on se dit la guerre du Golfe va être un
conflit à haute intensité
pour ceux qui se souviennent de cette
période là on se dit l'armée américaine
l'armée irakienne je crois qu'on dit
qu'elle c'est la quatrième armée au
monde donc on sait que c'est une armée
qui a de l'expérience ils ont des gaz de
combat et qu'on va sûrement se trouver
dans un conflit de haute intensité qui
dit confinement intensité des pertes
massives et dit perte psychique donc
l'armée française va prendre la décision
d'envoyer des psychiatres à proximité de
la ligne de front et on est vraiment
actuellement dans cette séquence
c'est-à-dire de se dire que oui il faut
des réanimateurs oui il faut des
chirurgiens mais il faut aussi des
psychiatres et on va construire la
doctrine actuelle à partir de cette
expérience de la guerre du Golfe il y
aura après lex Yougoslavie avec toute la
question de ces soldats des casques
bleus de la confrontation à la guerre
une guerre civile qui est
particulièrement difficile l'horreur de
la guerre civile je pense je pense au
siège de Sarajevo qui a été
particulièrement
difficile
plus tard l'Afghanistan en 2008 le choc
provoqué par l'embuscade 12 been c'est
10 soldats tués et ses 21 blessés
déclenche une prise de conscience
l'armée met en place un sas de fin de
mission pour les militaires pour
retrouver la paix intérieure avant le
retour
maintenant on imaginerait pas déployer
des militaires français sans qu'il y ait
un psychiatre
le médecin en chef Aurélie fait partie
de la trentaine de psychiatres du
service de santé des armées
engagé en 2013 elle est partie 4 fois en
mission
la première enjordanie pour l'opération
d'amour sur le camp de réfugiés syriens
de zattahari
les trois suivantes au Mali au profit de
l'opération barkhane ou la présence d'un
psychiatre est systématique
les rencontres entre militaires et
psychiatres sur le terrain sont
nombreuses souffrances liée à
l'éloignement familiale anxiété
dépression ou épuisement liées aux
conditions d'engagement c'est le cas
aussi après un événement grave lors de
débriefing collectif ou individuels
sur les débriefings l'important c'est
que ça se passe très rapidement à après
l'événement alors pas dans les premières
24 heures on est plutôt dans le domaine
du des fusils et c'est le rôle essentiel
du médecin des forces qui à la fois nous
prépare pour la suite pour les
débriefings
[Musique]
le débriefing va permettre en effet de
remettre en mots une expérience un
véhicule face à un événement
potentiellement traumatogène et ça
permet aussi non
le postimilia ne détecté des personnes
qui peuvent être peut-être plus en
difficulté et de mettre aussi un suivi
pour la suite
en mission le psychiatre militaire et
lui aussi soumis aux contraintes
opérationnelles
à mon sens ça permet
de toucher un peu de plus près les
contraintes auxquelles sont soumis les
militaires
de pouvoir
se représenter aussi ce qui est une
mission extérieure de vivre aussi
l'éloignement
familial ce qui voilà est pas toujours
évident
la guerre peut créer des blessures
psychiques mais difficile d'anticiper
les traumatismes
on a essayé les Anglais en 1941 avaient
mis en place qui s'appelait le war
School en se disant si on confronte des
soldats à des combattants à l'horreur du
champ de bataille on va quelque part les
blindés et on va en faire des surhommes
et n'auront pas de trauma ça n'a pas
marché l'autre idée qui a été suggéré
par certains c'est de supprimer les
émotions pas d'émotion pas trop mal
effectivement ça pourrait marcher est-ce
qu'on veut les soldats sans émotion bien
sûr que non
l'émotion c'est aussi un garde-fou c'est
c'est quelque chose qui suscitait de
l'émotion de l'empathie c'est important
donc il y a un prix à payer alors c'est
vrai que c'est un peu c'est un peu
provocateur de dire ça peut-être que le
trauma est à aussi un prix à payer à
cette confrontation à l'horreur
le service de santé des armées
expérimente des solutions comme une
nouvelle formation des combattants au
premier secours psychologique en
opération qui les prépare sur le terrain
à secourir un camarade choqué
mais la prévention réside avant tout et
surtout dans le suivi et le soutien
psychologique des militaires dès leur
engagement
Lorient en Bretagne
[Musique]
sur la base militaire des fusillés
marins commando les fameux commandos
marines reconnaissables à leur béret
vert une unité d'exception de la Marine
nationale spécialisée dans les
opérations de contre terroristes et de
libération d'otages de lutte contre les
narcotrafiquants et la piraterie
maritime
[Musique]
un niveau physique qui est conséquent
mais mais le mental est très important
que ça soit la résilience ça soit en
recherche des personnes qui qui ont une
grande autonomie qui ont des capacités
d'innovation d'adaptation etc donc c'est
un savant mélange de qualité mais qui ne
veut pas dire que elles sont
insubmersibles aux événements qu'elles
vont elles vont être confrontées et
qu'elles seront que toutes ces
difficultés vont glisser sur elle la
doucement du volet psychologique il est
il est impératif avant et après voilà
parce que parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on est fort spécial
qu'on n'est pas sujet à ces événements
et qu'on passera au travers bien au
contraire
la Marine nationale compte une trentaine
de psychologues répartis dans les 15
services locaux de psychologie
appliquées présents en métropole et en
outre-mer
dans le lieutenant de vaisseau Mathieu
infecté à Lorient depuis près de deux
ans
on a des gens qui sont au top
physiquement on a des gens qui sont au
top techniquement et ce qui va faire
qu'ils vont rester au top c'est aussi
que psychiquement et ils arrivent à
rester en bonne santé ça fait partie
d'un ensemble
une difficulté à laquelle on va se
heurter c'est que ce sont aussi des gens
qui ont cultivé leur tolérance à
l'effort la tolérance à la douleur sont
les gens qui cultivent le sens du
dépassement et donc quand il y a une
difficulté sont pas des gens qui vont
venir consulter spontanément et
l'intérêt pour nous c'est d'avoir une
proximité suffisante pour leur permettre
de consulter en tout cas de prendre
contact avec un psychologue avec un
médecin le plus rapidement possible on
va ta cellules au complet ou tu as déjà
du personnel déployer sur d'autres
gens de mission
après sur les autres mandats c'est
couvert par les psy des autres armées
et on a une collègue de Toulon qui qui
va partir là en fin d'année le
psychologue intervient dans toutes les
étapes de la vie du marin à leur
sélection dans leur formation pendant la
préparation des missions pour
sensibiliser au risque psychosociaux et
en cas de blessure lors des commissions
de suivi des blessés sans oublier le
soutien qu'il apporte à leur famille
en tant que chef d'un commando ou Pacha
d'un bâtiment de la Marine nationale le
capitaine de vaisseau Gaëtan s'est
appuyé sur le service de psychologie à
plusieurs reprises
nous sommes nos unités pendant longtemps
aller consulter c'était considéré aussi
comme un peu on a vu de faiblesse et se
mettre un peu à l'écarter à l'écart du
groupe et donc il y a eu un changement
en changement à tout niveau que ça soit
des opérateurs jusqu'à la chaîne de
commandement et donc il y a eu une prise
en compte plus globale et donc c'est
maintenant pleinement entrer dans les
mœurs
quand j'étais commandant dans le
commando ici ou au retour de mission
j'ai eu un de mes marins qui a eu un
double post-traumatique en échangeant
avec le service de psychologie de
manière assez tôt on a pu lui apporter
Lucien nécessaire et donc ça ça a été
pleinement bénéfique à la fois pour lui
et pour le groupe sachant qu'il a pu
être traité trop et rester au sein de
l'unité c'est pas une blessure honteuse
bien au contraire il n'y a pas de
blessure qui soit plus liée au respect
de l'engagement militaire si on a une
blessure psychique c'est bien qu'on a
respecté et qu'on a été au bout de ce
pourquoi on s'est engagé du service de
la France du
respect de son groupe de l'implication
pour son groupe du collectif du sens de
la mission etc
[Musique]
s'il reste parfois des mots que rien ne
peut apaiser le ministère des armées
continue de faire évoluer sa politique
d'accompagnement
pour Pascal William et David un nouvel
avenir se profile je me passionnément à
tout ce que j'ai pu faire dans ma
carrière militaire qui était ce qui
était dense j'ai vécu beaucoup plus que
tout ce que j'avais j'aurais imaginé
vivre c'est pas c'est une richesse
exceptionnelle que j'ai en moi que je
garde qui va qui m'a construit j'ai pris
conscience que je pouvais faire de
belles choses ou en tout cas pour suivre
mon engagement dans un autre domaine
donc je le fais ici pendant mon temps de
baisser en tant que community manager et
ambassadeurs et j'espère pouvoir
reprendre un cursus d'études supérieur à
l'avenir en intégrant sciences
politiques et pour pouvoir mener mon
engagement avec d'autres outils dans un
autre dans un autre milieu mais toujours
au service de de mon pays et surtout de
mes camarades l'hôpital m'a remis sur
pied
et Atos me réapprend à marcher il y a
peu de temps j'étais encore à penser que
ma vie était derrière aujourd'hui je
j'arrive à me projeter sur sur l'avenir
et ça c'est ouf c'est fort en émotion je
sens que j'ai je fais un progrès par
rapport au début de l'année le jour et
la nuit et je sens que c'est
une nouvelle étape qui démarre que
maintenant
je peux commencer à regarder devant à me
préparer pour la suite
[Musique]